only et was invited to her hometown of
Montreal to talk dating motherhood and
music in true Queen Celine fashion what
song gets you dancing with your boys
dancing on my I don't know get started
anytime Selene breaks into song we're
all in oh I'm a single ooh it was truly
special to hang with this single lady
you're where she grew up how do you feel
about being back home it's always great
it's in her native Canada where she
watches her courage world tour on
Wednesday night but it might get lonely
her three sons will be staying home in
Vegas you have said that they won't be
coming on the road with you that's the
first time the first time how difficult
will it be for you to be away from them
no more than two weeks though you said
well if I just think about me it will be
very different
what would be best for them is that they
would be home go to school play have a
good time now 51 years old this hot mama
is having fun with fashion and living it
up she's got a new album coming out in
November and there's a new guy in her
life Pepe Munoz who 17 years younger we
met and we bonded as best friends we
were laughing constantly we had to be
like children pay attention
calm down an immediate bond an immediate
bond but Pepe is not her boyfriend he's
a combination of friend confidante
stylist and choreographer do you think
you'll ever get to the point where you
do want to date again want to find
another love in your life that way I
don't know which way but it won't be
that way because the pay is gages to me
not that Bay I just want to make the
break-up straight here respect that I do
have that I know he's my best friend
[Music]
but like her most famous song says her
heart will go on am i gonna love again
am I gonna have a partner in my life
well stay tuned and if I do I will
definitely share it and it would be more
than my pleasure to share it it's it's a
chapter that is not it's not something
it's something that's close but it's not
something that's dead
[Music]